okay [ __ ] it's my psychobabble and
we're [ __ ] back and we're we're
coming with this ass there's no
installment okay bet I called wasps and
stain okay is it that is it you don't
know you just know that wasn't Jewish
anyway we're going to do this one let's
start it oh okay you get some sleep you
know my dream I smell a barbecue oh your
children Oh a dog okay
that bacon what is that love Benghazi
all right
or is this my second wife like it's
hidden you can never tell for me he's
barred he has to kiss the lady we'll
figure out which weapons of his it is
you know warriors without hide that's
the trickiest thing I'm at being blind
you know you get enough which life for
doing with oh okay
politics a 1940 section because what he
Lhari
oh yeah my choice go back into the
flight mech time to feel like agents a
skylight
hey you got a tape yeah got it baby
Kalinin you'll need plan some baling
wire
come into microphone man once you
[ __ ] tell me that in the first place
all right carbon shut I'm your chef okay
I'm not really an engineer so good with
cars a favor will be hard life for the
cargo bay doors I'm going are going
Kaizen they don't pay me enough for this
that's for sure yeah yeah yeah you can
we just give her a lot more don't pay me
after that
and that it
oh sorry
hey Dad God but a climbing no I talked
to the coffee pot to us
hey now what's up [ __ ]
yeah this is above my pay grade 10 cents
complete ultimate on it blast all right
yeah [ __ ] a lot of
hey-oh
[ __ ] it I can't tell what's our guy was
not I just shot on our flight for sure
you
barking hey
[ __ ] it kidding
oh it's yet it again okay what's guys
gonna hate out top hitting my head I'll
wake up your [ __ ] Sleep No More when
Jesus has any we peel off all right [ __ ]
socket shed a lot all right it's still
free than your jelly busted its offers
that come you know Jesus Christ there's
nice except this don't you are coming
bouncer one but I pretty much told music
let's catch him although neither sponsor
wants to throw the figis off- up to one
serious case of ambush your fiendish
several out of formation and you keep
the light rain plugins
get up up like you got here watchful
beautiful flavor they die
I'll bear my those flashing lights hey
you got it nice company - yeah I don't
know about that
appreciate your problem called all night
as you smoke I see solution coming up
you're wrong oh yeah you got a [ __ ] up
there dog chanting handled like a
concrete bridge [ __ ] that go tonight
comment on tonight does a troop
transport is that the being a call me
comment on tonight the time I find a
wine tonight but I bear boy was it
awfully close attention II know you see
the pilots with all the way our beds
engine agglomerates hydrogen carbon
I pull it towards you don't dynamite to
keep it level just pull your badge on or
don't have a loud
[Music]
Megan watch out
okay straight away it said I need you to
do one more thing for me have a man's
ready by the side door
yeah I get visited where last--which
can the cockpit door open you're gonna
have to hold it
are you sure sir it seems to like
against FAA regulation
holy [ __ ] like this [ __ ] marker and
then they were [ __ ] crazy here okay
things are getting actively work things
are getting actively work
now face her thank you
[Music]
[Music]
what's the score yes
we talk of my son
say my way hi guys [ __ ] Rosser you
say that
[Applause]
let some [ __ ] here huh is cried let's go
sucker loosen it keep it together get
your [ __ ] together why not going to get
this point my lord my problem at me get
up that high like it go somewhere that
call me that I shouldn't get work
okay we got lunch is this a fight I
don't they'll say I'll be honest I'm now
first up with those clothes from
Wilson's this war
that's its compounds coming up oh is it
gonna be appalled by Glasgow
but on a bad chef let me get the state
and I sit down you all [ __ ] egg oh
[ __ ] it in your [ __ ] chair don't sit
down break it off
beautiful May July 16 1940 it as you are
machine is advancing at an astonishing
rate we can't catch up catch us our
family how glad I do this yeah what the
[ __ ] is that not me I'm here to see and
all this was cool he doesn't wake up
[ __ ] like being under how did I can
have my face match
take my ex-wife Fergus what you said
your boy barking laughter we've got a
skipper the fog wiggle here dropped
inside of that car of some kind of a
comet healthy - trying to [ __ ] eat it
so joke big problem here
Shaq does not get rich over there
just like a white fluffy light chuckles
can you see the light right there white
something like that off I get that it's
like a dog why didn't it on your do they
animate that talk--i there's an odd
position although they [ __ ] drop it
in but you got says a concrete on it on
this here that's awesome I be able to
kill me like an [ __ ] I'm sure the
work on bug at all it help you to swim
is just keep your head down below the
surface should be alright good plan
first coming to each version is my boy
well it's a sad thought this head should
have killed that man okay I get how
swimming now it's time I made up they'll
use my girls
I've grown enough [ __ ] out of her and
she's ready to breathe what is that
go coin just popped Marian out of my way
you [ __ ] basics look this is a nice
way past the basics okay
this is what I deal with that right now
right out of my way [ __ ] and excuse me
place [ __ ] bodies in the way Shepard
hurry dude I don't know how my breakfast
blogger
all right guys right here alright here I
go
go suck a deck you [ __ ]
all right push it up
let's hyper machine-gun Astorino
stretches over there
we can advance the unit without being
slaughtered so I want to move ugly Oh
eyes those trenches and take the master
just run as fast as you possibly bloody
can straight up the middle
will they don't come five minute guys I
pour this on a radio update to another
position quite nice you ready to lay
down suppressive fire
okay get right there in there ah [ __ ] it
isn't that
shut
they're gonna eat laughing oh that's
right out the window old job Moscow will
need the rest might have enough troubles
without walking Nazi war machine no tree
to find an entrance to the cliffside
bunker there are two colors out there
and easy to eliminate I'll take a little
counter blaskowitz obscene foot and you
will show the cat to the obligatory yes
kinda gets on my machine
and wake up why's he like that
this is look each set is hepatech
just something I just saw like a helmet
or going amazing
[ __ ] [ __ ] a there's no way to go
not a really nice way out it
[ __ ] is that [ __ ] this is good [ __ ] here
sorry fetch s and they went to ignore
yell just preoccupied oh [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of my light bets yeah I
can I would like that you just stop with
this [ __ ] fire - look you don't have
to [ __ ] late
fuckin'-a
you know I like about this so far though
is that like it's pretty I get why they
do them though okay so you were on ammo
pretty quickly put the hammer everywhere
so you keep the fortune to move it makes
action
she prayed up oh [ __ ]
that's not hot I get why they do it the
thing is like because of that you're
[ __ ] constantly in just like pressing
X will also put interiors which we kind
of are
and a hand
not really a takedown guy now
shall ready go [ __ ] it [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] they ask you blow up some
products on the upper levels of the
glyph cycle yeah simple the motion
commotion people in the animals counted
up lost and I think of this guy a lot of
[ __ ] ammo of a scam I'm a headache
for some reason I don't know why which I
did but I just know enemies in here
where I I supposed to be here it's like
a [ __ ] mole what is this I guess
[Music]
check back and laugh
fuckin'-a fuckin'-a for these masters
color from anybody know so many pocket
mazie the ladies an asset nobody knows
really nobody knows nicer Genesis sorry
for the hate [ __ ] but a target penis
in here
Yeah right amount of up okay applause go
on
we made it positive stomping get Amanda
to the cliff wall directly below deaths
heads Kampai
yeah yes sir I don't know what work
you're talking about but I agree with
you I agree with what you're putting out
is what I'm saying
Wow we shop it you'll [ __ ] your [ __ ]
shoot your legs okay if you like your
legs I feel bad for you just shot okay
give me that time yeah I can I can I met
good eyes go suck a dick Oh
fighting about climbing the cliff wall
below the console how do you look very
hard to keep signal mammoth same time
all right I got batch
did I think blow up
sherrod I get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
if they get stuck oh [ __ ] you
get this thing died
I'm shooting a lot
[ __ ] here's the Kansa okay I guess at
the map was this Dale yo come on [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] dodge that oh it's a
pretty goodness get headings a journal
they tell you everything what are you
doing ich bin line guys I'm fine but
link mask it's going real
[ __ ] ready go
I'm an armor that's what oh [ __ ]
what's in here
Oscar's letter well I'm not rating
because you still left with a [ __ ] K
that zaps [ __ ] weird mouse [ __ ] mice
in here
who's shooting at me make that [ __ ]
fighting war captain hey hey Wyatt much
as I adore the view from up here
will you please for the love of only
mother Jesus find a godforsaken Road
this sucker is talking about fetch and
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] going on here
what is right Oh like a dog take my hand
I'll help you up by the Wyatt again
I'm sure to return the favor so resent
why did I slapped earlier Judi pay
attention boys it's all time for the
gusandjess okay assay work dude yeah
delegated welcome to the war takeover
now general Gentek is merely two
personalities right now right must be
willing to know that private should I
feel like they're not exactly why they
really want to kill come ahead college
like we don't are gonna have us what I
exist like let's be honest like surely
bad guy but like for color pencil
talking either
they got me objection no - yes nurse
Mikey connected go beyond the rock me
jacked off for example I guess my
handsome [ __ ] side so we ready that
lot there's time great yeah that's y'all
gone now let's go let's do that second
Sunday church walk come on you like that
you like that that's how much a good
time like this any other like chronic
dry I think I should go
kumquat question date Thanks
your job is simple climb up this wall
look in the consumer this big [ __ ]
oil and Sapphire take ours
yes we can incite people work away up to
the building court find that said we
should have in our head
you got a bro look with that ax just
like on the [ __ ] moon
we don't allow travelers because I say
that you're on the same road I am today
make me [ __ ] dizzy all this [ __ ]
- a lot good for me again I'd like to
emphasize those r-robber that I just
know their faces and they're gonna like
I feel like take you senator they
ignored okay
don't open the wind up yet yeah dirty
sketch got my lap I am old what are they
yes match
yes there's that batch biggest colors
I did say will come that's up to you I
lost quits open the gate alright
Mangalore ey where where am I got this
dark now that's what Oh down here no
this is our way
dan
let's go back and that's looking pretty
smooth but I can I try setting up
towards the top frost will they get out
oh it top lawyers [ __ ] just jump down
put the near [ __ ] lift that [ __ ] up
here or I'll [ __ ] dog
very [ __ ] upper when you got so much
makeup go suck a deck you [ __ ] stick
like that second I said right there
guys suck a dick you [ __ ] dick I hear
what ah thank you
to Commission Italy services here
general waste your pain
guys like very angry like I get I have
an angry about [ __ ] like taxes chef but
like chases this guy's pissed that a guy
like probably never I'm at
yeah pocket okay kit use it up summer
for ammo
shut that bread and I like this bread
said we still may have a way to fatten
okay what is that a croc trap to frame
good ass [ __ ] I don't read German
I like to be honest I've never read
German oh [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] hurt you [ __ ] shopping Wow
I got like no ammo 10-ounce games closed
Barrow
yeah that's a good [ __ ] here Scott and
I'm on a call right there betcha
hi
back down to my Shangaan huh
fine Nazi killing them sir thank you sir
everybody loves comments like we'll be
back to see more health
transport the [ __ ] come to be
proposition which pops up about points
do you get the movie screen from your
position
are you really transferred you got this
summer thanks for okay can we hurry up
it all here
no like I look like he was talking ready
I take my gun back to throw it together
guys bucks [ __ ] scary [ __ ]
grab my hands bench hello I'm sliding
here you gotta grab my hand I like that
hello [ __ ] chip while I ask your hold on
guys yeah okay Oh tucking it into my
head yeah you are what you eat [ __ ]
you bar what you ate oh that's why I'm
bacon pop you two broken
yeah Oh some sex onion [ __ ] hello sir
hello sir
Oh hola yeah wait it she didn't find a
way to open our goal we're better ma
Lana why anyway I'm blaskowitz
yeah prob and then drop it son god
all right trinkets comics iteration turn
it off from the files that really shout
to play this one so you put on their
face war there's if you want I'm so
sorry this appeal what do it by the King
yeah suck it even put a [ __ ]
protectable game oh [ __ ] we're all likes
nothing like that hey boy I got a
[ __ ] leg oh yeah well this dude
laughs Zak you can guess my lunch later
right now I need this thank you
yeah well that's what you get last time
I set my arms for Amara for you would
have to quite that share the beginning
and I guess I thank you [ __ ] is that
always set how do you describe a
physical I don't really know what that
mean I am sure they are the face [ __ ]
holy yeah that was [ __ ] up hell out
there are you okay they're gonna make
and hang out there anyway to get that
door we'll get you out of here a lot of
aunties leaving the most of them hold on
I can hear someone else there's so much
coming Hey oh no [ __ ] mr. ugly he's so
ugly
right
yes
Seth hey I know what lucky to be in
today
but now he says it I died
let's get our people I like that so many
that I lost count
oh shut you see me before
oh yeah we met you I could do great
things I have two acts are what happened
here hey do you just get exposed to
cancer I remember right on here hey why
do make a second where Mugsy the great
bass so predicament well what I are rare
not easy one somebody throw pit all
dated yeah sorry yeah hello joy without
opinion really fun of these two
varieties what best support a server at
mph gasser
I have elected room percenters sir would
you decline my
folks in an e-mail or tape no no I don't
want that to take up and watch me thank
you thank you for being me Demoman X
cube to the one you look at me dissect
yeah no problem but this guy yeah I
don't like it
I slot the slot for like $25 we [ __ ]
get [ __ ] up again you will pay me
won't deter [ __ ] like [ __ ] Channing
Tatum we're going to attack what is this
Magic Mike teaching me a lesson it's
like the [ __ ] up person if I took my
friend into people make them I look too
far I thought I'd seen it all I've never
seen true cruel Oh No why are you
letting them uncle taught by larry i am
captain form
[Music]
are we going to do if I want to make you
again their acceptance to die happy time
you'll know what to do
yes it's another generator I can't tell
what's to pay we're off to the [ __ ]
guys block then sucking getting up [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] am i down arrows [ __ ] him up
like blazing fire normally including a
herd of oxen usually tough and a problem
sir gramma
we did it
[ __ ] fiance's neither can i down with
over come on I'll get you out of those
truck I'm right here
like I'll go see about broken feet you
get a Tom Wizzle every skinning and
that's the window now you should rip my
[ __ ] ankle huh
oh oh oh [ __ ] who can I detect both
scream oh okay yeah that's it
Oh Sharon Tate oh oh [ __ ] that's going
to throw my modeling career after short
[ __ ] office
[ __ ] come pop as a mofo puppet as a
software thank you thank you
present a Channing Tatum and Magic Mike
three okay bye Jenna Tatum variant
bashang game second
that was a game I'm so [ __ ]
and so cold my nipples are as hard as
rocks
somebody's Joe animals somebody well if
it's done the no otter that
[Music]
is that drowning it's [ __ ] floating
calif is closed cut up my clothes [ __ ]
don't illegal so much shrapnel nine
weeks don't shave my face for me or do I
just not grow hair don't go shoot me
Edwards yes I ate a lot of scrambled
eggs again
I love scrambled eggs all right I guess
I line that there thank y'all for
watching thank ya